parce que le vrai problème de tout ça
c'est pas qu'un problème d'organisation
g les soignants de réa de l'hôpital de
chalon viennent d'écrire aujourd'hui au
président la république j'ai leur lettre
je n'adhérais pas mais c'est exactement
ce qui pointe c'est pas un problème
organisation c'est un problème de moyens
matériels nous ne sommes pas calibré
pour faire face à ces crises sanitaires
et donc ce que fait monsieur macron
c'est dire finalement je n'ai pas vu de
moyens supplémentaires alors j'étais
quasi convaincu comme la totalité de la
planète qu'on allait avoir une deuxième
vague mais jeu cadenassé la france ce
soir parce que j'ai peu de l'hydre et a
en tout cas je n'ai aucun
supplémentaires et par conséquent vous
allez rester chez vous parce que je veux
pas vous voir faire des files d'attentes
et mourir doucement dans les couloirs
des hôpitaux
c'est ça la réalité donc il ya des
responsabilités mais ce député
honnêtement vous n'avez pas le meilleur
rôle ce soir mais à partir de là vous
avez au moins le courage d'être là et
d'avoir dit aussi que très tôt vous avez
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé mais gouverner
c'est aussi est responsable aujourd'hui
moi je vois un président de république
qui n'a pas été responsable dans sa
mission et qui viennent nous dire si
vous qui allez payer ma propre incurie
et ça c'est intolérable
c'est même insoutenable donc en gros on
est en train de cadenasser certaines
professions qui travaillent après 21h
sachant qu'on pense qu'à peu près
simplement 10% des contaminations se
passe à partir de ce moment là et donc
on n'a pas réglé les neuf dixièmes du
problème mais par contre on les condamne
à des perspectives absolument noir
effectivement ces quatre semaines ces
six semaines et président a bien parlé
de décembre on l'a tous entendu donc ça
va il a pris des engagements réalistes à
venir concrètement la main une
préparation de l'opinion face a été
redit c'est effectivement de la
communication c'est une communication
présidentielle mais il prépare l'opinion
à des mesures qui risquent de durer moi
je voulais juste souligner quelque chose
c'est que vous parlez à juste titre des
mesures compensatoires ou dead qui
peuvent arriver
pour ces professions très bien mais je
devrais avoir un mot pour les personnes
qui gravitent autour de ces professions
et qui elles ne sont pas directement
aidé je prends un exemple pardonnez moi
comment par exemple je viens de
bourgogne franche comté et j'ai des amis
vignerons ça n'étonnera personne pour
cette région dont un qui sait après midi
était en train de faire le tour de ses
clients habituels des restaurants et des
bars tous nous ont dit on prend la
commande mais on met une clause
suspensive
si ce soir on nous annonce un couvre-feu
la commande est annulée
il repart chez lui il est à paris ce
soir que
salut il repart chez lui il a zéro
bouteilles vendues donc et les appâts
dead et pour lui il y aura aucune aide
surprend simplement cet exemple là pour
vous montrer qu'en fait on a créé les
conditions d'une onde de choc économique
qui vont non seulement qu'il va non
seulement touché les professions
concernées c'est-à-dire celles qui
travaillent encore après 21h mais toutes
celles qu'elles font vivre autour et ça
ça avait-il chose de dramatique
c'est sans doute une des solutions les
plus durs c'est celle qui a été
appliquée je le regrette encore une fois
on est élu vous êtes élue je suis dans
ma commune on agit en responsabilité et
il me semble que là il ya une faute
énorme de la part du président dans le
public et collectivement du gouvernement
je veux bien entendre on n'a peut-être
pas voulu le voir un moment donné mais
gouverner c'est agir mais avant d'agir
c'est prévoir et là on met tout le monde
dans une situation extrêmement
compliquée le pays est très fragile
économiquement nous n'avons pas la santé
économique de l'allemagne par exemple
nous n'avons pas la santé économique de
tas de pays nous relèverons nous demain
parce que pour payer les aides que vous
dites échos que l'on souhaite évidemment
pour ces professions l'état arrive à
récupérer des impôts et pour ça faut que
l'économie ne soit pas à l'arrêt or nous
sommes un des pays les plus impactés sur
le plan économique par ce qui se passe
depuis quelques mois
est ce que le président vient décidé ce
soir ça va rajouter de la crise à la cre